was the key to successful relationship
was like what are the things you see
time and time again that do you
designate this they're on a good path
yeah there's a real Attunement honestly
just it's
um sort of an us against the world
feeling nobody neither partner is going
to talk on them the other uh
there's a loyalty
um they handle each other in the
relationship with care
you can tell that they've worked some
things I to me
it usually indicates that these are some
people who figured they've had to work
some things out they know that this is
delicate they know
um you know that you're on thin ice you
take a wrong step and you can be back in
a tough place in your relationship or
you treat it with care and it can be
amazing
so they're careful with one another they
give each other compliments they are
considerate so you'll see
um you know he'll bring the car around
for her because it's raining or
um
she'll bring him home some takeout you
know she'll order for him to at the
restaurant there's just they keep each
other in each other's minds would that
us against the world thing
that definitely is there like 100 you've
seen that right yeah you've seen it and
you've seen it like um I like it when
couples have been together for a long
time and when one is talking the other
one looks at them if you don't do that
that's not a bad sound but it's a good
sign when you do that yes because uh and
I think it's actually a really good
um exercise to do because I because I
enjoy when I see in others so it's it's
a
it's a way to show that you don't take
them for granted and then you still find
them like this mysterious wonderful
creature to observe like I think too
often we have that with our parents we
have that with um people close to us you
think yeah I've heard what they're about
to say I know I know you can complete
that sentence take them for granted and
then if you if you just look at them and
say wow this is the most brilliant
person
I've ever seen in my life most I can't
you know
just appreciate every word that comes
out of them and look at them in that way
you actually begin to believe it yeah
and you actually begin to see the beauty
of what they're saying you are exactly
right it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
and it's caring yeah yeah it's very
caring so that's I mean that's I think
the beauty of what the gottman research
showed us taught us provided us is that
we can do these things that become
cyclic and just keep growing this
relationship making it stronger more
powerful more loving you would never
want to cut it down well we you were
talking about the sheet for conflict
processing what are we talking about so
like a couple will come and say like
there was this conflict and you put on
the table and then what does it mean to
process it so in that gottman method of
therapy there are all these different I
mean hundreds of different interventions
and based on what the issue is in that
session you can decide the most
appropriate intervention and so this is
a specific intervention for if it is a
conflict that occurred and there are
different types of conflicts so this
would be more like an incident it's not
a Perpetual recurring problem
um which has actually a different
intervention where you kind of look at
the underlying belief systems values and
there's the goal is not to solve that
problem the goal in that situation is to
actually just get a better understanding
of each other and your positions and
just
you stop seeing your partner as the
adverse area and you start seeing them
as a person who makes sense
but if there's been a specific event a
specific fight that's just sort of
situational
uh but it's left Bad Blood things were
said or you didn't feel understood this
intervention I was talking about is one
that you would go through a series of
steps where first you identify the
emotions that you were feeling
then you describe play by play your
movie your perspective if your partner
we're looking through your eyes this is
what they heard saw thought then they
saw this then they heard this so you're
not saying yeah then you came in were
yelling and acting crazy you're saying
so then I saw you come in
I heard you say and I thought to myself
well great now everything's ruined right
so you're showing them your movie then
they have to summarize the movie for you
and then vice versa
and then there's this um Step where each
person validates some part that they can
understand like based on what you saw
heard I can't actually understand how
you felt one of those feelings that you
said then my favorite part is you rewind
sort of the movie
from that day back through into
childhood and you land on a time a
memory when you felt a similar set of
feelings
and this is like the most beautiful part
ever because let's say the feeling was I
felt misunderstood I felt
um misjudged uncared about unloved like
you didn't even like me and I'll say
when did you feel that way you know land
on a time and they're like my whole
childhood you know my parents were my
mom was always accusing me of doing
things I wasn't doing and it would set
me up and my dad would come home he'd
hear about it he would just believe her
and then you have like a partner
climbing up on the couch like give their
partner a hug while they're sharing the
story it's beautiful and it changes the
way you interact in future disagreements
so you have those moments yeah you can't
unlearn now you know this about your
partner you know what they're sensitive
to
yeah and again you kind of see the the
Beauty and the flaws then right
it all makes sense yeah it all kind of
makes sense yeah so you maybe were in
this dumpster dive in your head of how
your partner sucks and all the things
that are wrong with them and it's so
hopeless and then you get this light
shining through and you realize oh my
god of course they would be sensitive to
that and suddenly it's not about all the
ways your partner is wrong and proving
that they're wrong it's just how can I
in the future make sure they do not feel
this again I would never want this
person I love to misunderstand me and
feel so unloved